Did you guys ever see the Blair witch
project?
How many of you have seen that?
How many of you haven't?
Oh,
so it's a pretty lousy example.
Anyways,
it's a horror movie now.
There's kind of two kinds of horror
movies.
There's the splatter type horror movie
and I think actually those expose you to
discuss and then there's the fear kind
of horror movie and that doesn't need to
have any Gore at all.
It just makes you afraid.
And the Blair witch project is very good
example of that because all that
happens,
nothing happens,
but you think something terrible is
going to happen every second and the
sense that something terrible is gonna
happen,
keeps climbing through the whole movie
and so what they do is put you in a
state of radical uncertainty and never
let you off.
Okay,
well,
so basically they're playing with your
imagination and that can work very
effectively.
Like it's often horror movies,
often more effective if they don't show
you what's making those horrible noises
off screening,
you know,
because no matter what they show you,
the probability that he can be as
personally horrible as what other
monsters you're dredging up out of your
imagination is very low.
So,
and you know,
what's reasonable to be afraid of the
dark because throughout our biological
history,
lots of unfortunate people were devoured
by things in the dark or hurt very badly
by them,
etc.
Etc.
And wE're also daytime creatures,
right?
So we don't like the dark very much.
So what do you do to someone if you're
going to initiate them is maybe you take
them when they're 13 and you put them in
a really dark cave and caves.
There Are so dark man,
like if you're in a cave,
you just can't believe how dark it is.
It's,
it's.
You can't see anything in a cave.
So you don't know how big the space
you're in is and you don't know how
small it is and you don't know whether
or not it's going to collapse or when
it's going to stay up.
And you don't know how far you are
underground,
especially if the people who took you
there didn't,
you know,
walked around in circles and did let you
know where you were going and then maybe
they leave and maybe they leave for
three days.
And so you're sitting down there
thinking,
well,
what are you thinking?
Exactly?
Well,
you're thinking the most horrible
thoughts you could possibly imagine,
right?
I'm never going to get out of here.
They're never going to find me again.
some horrible snake thing that lives in
the darkness is going to come and eat me
slowly because fast would be merciful
and I'm and then I'm also going to go
completely out of my mind so that even
if something doesn't eat me,
I'm going to come over here.
it will be worse than being dead
anyways.
And so partly what you're doing in that
circumstances,
you're facing that demons of your own
imagination.
And if you can stand that,
then you grow up.
And that's what an initiation ceremony
tests.
Now,
a lot of what you'll find if you look at
clinical theories of psychology,
the same motif applies if you want to
get better,
you have to find out what you're
avoiding and what you're afraid of and
maybe what you're by you and you have to
expose yourself to that voluntarily and
you have to let that change you,
and so it's not a pleasant prospect.
I mean,
it's not dancing through a field of
daisies,
right?
With muzak play and it'S not follow your
bliss.
You know?
It's not the natural unfolding of a
positive process.
It's not that at all.
It's the voluntary confrontation with
the things that make up life horrors.
But what's interesting about it is that
there's.
There's an idea there that lurks under
the surface archetypally,
and that is there's a lot more to you
than meets the eye,
but it won't be released unless it has
to,
and so you're not going to even figure
out what it is until you put yourself in
peril.
Now,
part of that you might think like
imagine that you're.
You're an introvert.
You're socially awkward,
you're highly neurotic,
so you feel a lot of anxiety and
depression.
You don't like going to partieS.
That's because the horrible pirate lives
at parties and always glaring at you and
judging you and telling you how useless
and insufficient you are.
And so you go there.
You don't even look at people because
you know that if you did look at them,
you just see the face of the judgmental
tyrant,
which by the way,
you wouldn't if you actually looked at
them,
but you won't because you avoid and so
you're going to go there and you're
going to put yourself in this terrible
situation and if you're lucky and you're
a bit of weight,
then you're going to incorporate all
sorts of information from the external
world that will help you develop your
social skills and make you more
sophisticated.
And even if that doesn't happen,
you're going to learn that.
You can tolerate your own fear.
And you might say,
well,
what's better to not be afraid or to
know that you can handle being afraid
and obviously to not be afraid,
but give that up because that ain't
happening so that the next best thing
and the realistic thing is to know that
you're the master of your own fear.
And so a lot of what we're going to talk
about in relationship to classical
theories of personality is exactly that.
It's not that the world isn't terrible,
it's that the world is terrible,
but you're a lot stronger than you think
and the way you.
Okay?
And so part of that is the strength that
you gather is partly the information
that you gather when you go somewhere
that you're not good at.
You know,
so you're establishing new skills like
you haven't university.
But there's another part that's
interesting that's related to the little
video that I showed you at the
beginning.
Dna turns out to be a very complex
structure.
And so if I put you in situation a,
then dna codes,
certain kinds of proteins that help make
up the way that your mind is in the way
it works.
But if I take you and put you in another
situation,
completely different genes turn on,
and so what that means is that you have
a biological repository of potential use
lying dormant at the highest resolution
level of your molecular structure,
and that if you push yourself and all
sorts of different directions and you
find different things to pursue and test
yourself against,
then you're going to turn on parts of
yourself that aren't currently on and
god only knows what you'd be like.
If you turned yourself completely on.
Maybe I could use a better metaphor.
I'll tell you a little bit more about
the shavano routines because they're
more in a way,
if there is a initiation archetype,
which I kind of just described,
which is you can do this for yourself
and this is a good way to live.
BeaTs the alternative anyway.
So which is like the definition of a
good way to live so mad and you're
trying to pursue something so you've got
a goal.
That's a good thing.
You've got to have a goal and you don't
want to hold onto that too tightly
because he might be wrong.
You've got to be willing to let that go
and have a different goal,
but you need to go and then you know
while you're pursuing the goal,
you're going to find out that there's
some obstacles in your path,
obviously,
and maybe some of those obstacles are
afraid,
frightening,
tight.
Well,
maybe the reason of a disgusting type,
you might say,
I don't want to turn it into that kind
of person,
so those of you who are sort of
socialist utopia had left wingers might
think that way about business people.
It's like,
I wouldn't.
I would recommend that you get over it
as rapidly as possible.
So anyways,
you might think there's no way I'm going
to act that way.
So you sort of put it off limits saying,
or maybe you're afraid to do what you
need to do next.
Well,
here's the rule.
Don't avoid doing things because they
make you feel negative emotion.
If you have to do those things in order
to pursue your goals,
in fact,
you should do exactly the opposite.
So let's say you're pursuing a goal and
you find that you're afraid about
something and so you're avoiding it.
The first thing you should think is a
hot look.
I'm afraid of something and I'm avoiding
it.
Dragon treasure.
Exactly there.
And that's exactly right.
It's precisely right.
If you're.
If you're afraid of the thing,
then what that means is that you're not
developed enough to handle it and you
need to be.
So you should think about that as a
discovery,
like a positive discovery.
You found out where you have a weakness
and you're now able to address it.
So you know if you're an introvert and
you think it's friday night,
I could go to this party,
but you know I really don't want it.
Then you think,
oh,
that means I should go.
And that's exactly right because
because you already know how to do the
things that you know how to do and it's
the things that you don't know how to do
that bother you and oppress you.
And of course those things are going to
be difficult to learn about,
but you need to learn about them because
you need to get yourself all switched
on.
How's that switched on?
Because then you'll be able to tolerate
the fact that life is fundamentally
suffering and so you don't know.
The world doesn't get safer us.
You developed,
in fact quite the contrary.
You just get more competent and that's
better anyways because it's that you
don't want safety anyways.
You probably want adventure.
You probably want to be compelled.
You probably want to be engaged.
You know,
if you want security,
you might as well be dead well because
nothing's happening then and that
there's no danger level.
To be alive is to be contending with
the,
with the world and you want to be the
best at that that you can possibly be.
And that's partly what we're gonna learn
about as we go through the entire
course.
But certainly the elements that have to
do with clinical psychology because all
of the circulate around this fundamental
fee,
they have to.
Because it's the fundamental story of
mankind and we want to know what that
fundamental story is because we're all
human and you need to know the story and
then you know,
you can decide how you're gonna act it
out,
but at least you need to know the damn
story first.